the hair is you know hairing we're doing
the best we can everyone's doing the
best they can well isn't this unexpected
you know what else is unexpected bam I
assume future me has titled this
something like unexpected side effects
of breast cancer treatment how do you
make that sound sexy today I am going to
be talking about some of the more
unexpected or slightly surprising side
effects that happened for me and in the
spirit of unexpected I'm doing a massive
sex toy giveaway in this video as well
record player scratch yeah before you
create an opinion just remember that
stranger things have happened in the
world of old hellig in the last 365 days
so maybe it's easier just to go with it
and it also actually ties in really well
with what I want to talk about in this
video that we will get to which is the
very common but still slightly uh
surprising side effect of the loss of
sex drive during your chemo treatment
also if you are a member of my family
you don't need to watch this video
probably but if you're not a family
member stay with me now that I'm coming
out of chemo treatment and a lot of
these side effects that I'm talking
about are going away of course it's the
perfect time to give away vibrators to
be quite honest I don't think there is a
wrong time to give away free vibrators
Bessa have you heard of them if you
haven't do you have an internet
connection don't mind me I'm just
getting hives I get excited so my body
goes into fight or flight it doesn't
know the difference between excitement
and there's a predator in the room let's
talk about some sex toys I didn't know
that I would be uttering those sentences
this year but I didn't know that I would
be a breast cancer survivor this year
either let's embrace all of it which
aligns perfectly with bsa's mission
statement which is to empower everyone
to embrace explore and celebrate their
sexuality as someone that now finally
feels like I can enter the world of
Celebration this aligns with me the good
people over at Bessa are giving
literally everyone that signs up for
this this give away a vibrator or a gift
card for a
vibrator get one the best part about the
company is the packaging is super
discret this is how they showed up at my
door and the products are high quality
wonderful the pebble they come in these
discreet little charging
cases oops I open put it upside down can
you say it can say it can say it I had
to suction vibration controlled
independently ergonomically built to
perfectly fit in your hands see no
annoying pattern modes you know what I'm
talking about little discret charging
cases boom it's like a little horny poly
pocket the air Vibe look at this can you
see it can you see it can you see it
dual stimulation eyebrow raise eyebrow
raise wink waterproof for when you're
out in the rain rechargeable for when
you're camping silent for when you're at
the movies the thumb what a name what
the heck is this a pair of glasses no
it's a vibrator that does it all
vibrates suctions thum
see it see it see it this utilizes
bess's pleasure jet technology wao
listen to this Innovative thump
technology for natural clitoral
palpitations on the back of the pop grip
popsockets could never and they
shouldn't that's not what they're made
for again waterproof USB chargeable and
made from premium quality silicone this
is designed to be the de facto
replacement for all external
stimulating Vibes quite a mouthful those
she said we don't need to
anthropomorphize l in the bio they are
giving everyone that enters this
giveaway a vibrator or a gift card for a
vibrator it is discreet so get in
there I know you insert I can words are
sensitive when you talk about this we're
having fun we're having fun by the way
my eyebrows have started growing back in
I just keep touching them and that's so
fun can you see it can you see it can
you see it look at those little hairs
proud of you excited and flooded with
thoughts words like flooded are
different once you set up a video giving
away sex chice okay I will be doing a
video in the future where I'm going to
go through all the products specifically
that worked for me during my treatment
but for this video I just wanted to kind
of talk about some of the unexpected
side effects um emotionally physically
sexually that came up for me I'm about
to start my radiation part of treatment
and that will have its own side effects
but for now I just wanted to touch on
the side effects that happen during
chemo for anyone that spent any time
doing research on side effects of chemo
these are probably not so unexpected but
for someone like me who got very
overwhelmed when I started looking up
things about chemo before I was in it
these surprised me I want to talk about
some of the side effects that were less
common than the nausea hair loss fatigue
those are all the things that I think
everyone kind of generally expects
during chemo so I wanted to talk a
little bit about the things that are
less expected some of this stuff I've
touched on before but I thought it might
be helpful to just put it all in one
video again I had triple positive breast
cancer and the treatment was a cocktail
of drugs that went under the acronym
tchp I'll put up here this is what those
stand for so during my first chemo
session I got sent home with ooh a handy
dandy pamphlet of a variety of dark dark
and depressing information this is just
general notes on what to expect which is
super helpful this is a very short book
in terms of the length of the average
book out there so it wasn't too
overwhelming instead it was just very
helpful to give a general overview
contents section what is cancer how is
cancer treated what other reactions or
side effects can be anticipated diarrhea
guidelines constipation guidelines
really important stuff here I might as
well start with the reason I thought it
would be fun to give away sex toys in
this video and get right into the sex
drive of it all this little booklet has
a section called effects on sexuality so
why was this unexpected to me in the
beginning of treatment you were so
overwhelmed with everything your new
reality all of the medications you have
to remember the panic and anxiety of the
anticipation of what side effects you
might encounter everyone reacts to chemo
differently the whole experience is
really overwhelming and it's really hard
to keep accounting for what's going on
at least for me I would get into kind of
emotional spirals or anxiety spirals
trying to keep up with monitoring how
many different and competing things were
happening in my body so like this book
says cancer treatment causes a variety
of sexual side effects the most common
sexual side effect is just overall loss
of Desire libido especially for me with
triple positive breast cancer try trying
to avoid explaining the actual science
of it because I know that that is not my
strong suit triple positive or her two
positive breast cancer is a type of
breast cancer that occurs when breast
cancer cells use estrogen receptors
progesterone receptors and the human
epidermal growth factor to her two
protein to grow so basically you're giv
hormones that stop those cells from
getting those things and continuing to
grow I was given Lupron which
essentially shuts down my ovaries and
stops them from
producing estrogen so that those cells
can't feed on that and Grow Again
someone that is smarter than me can make
this make sense in the comments Lupron
because it shuts down your ovaries
basically pushes you into a menopausal
State amid all of the normal nausea
fatigue
diarrhea I was also experiencing
menopausal symptoms I know that I look
uncomfortable talking about this that's
just how my body moves but the reality
is I do want to expl explain some of
this because I think it's really
important that there's not something
wrong with you your body is literally
forced into a menopausal State and so I
was experiencing hot flashes mood swings
I lost my period all together which is
very common some experienc either
irregular Menses or just the loss of
their period completely bing bing bing
save money on tampons though there was a
huge shift in libido for me in the fact
that it wasn't there at all on top of
just the general hormonal changes that
are happening in your body your body is
just not feeling well so the idea of um
experiencing any sensation close to
horniness was not in the picture for me
at all the only thing I got horny for
was a blanket and a bed and strictly to
lay down and watch TV for me I didn't
even realize that that was a major side
effect until over halfway through
treatment just so many other things that
were going on and emotions to process
and bodily Sensations to manage it
didn't even occur to me that I was also
experiencing menopausal symptoms and
being able to understand and accept that
and also say it out loud just really
helped me not get into a tail spin that
like something was really wrong with me
on top of the tumor that was growing
inside of me hugely important to
recognize that this is a biological
byproduct of what your body is being put
through especially with wrapping up
chemo it's it's not like you finish and
then boom everything's back to normal
you have to slowly get back into your
new normal and learning to trust your
body and getting back in touch with your
libido is part of that eyebrow raise
eyebrow raise wink there's so many
things that affect so many things I had
a complete response but I still have
other things um to tackle that will
affect my body so it's an ongoing
process to befriend your body again
after the crazy that it went
through it's some crazy there's a
lot of reconnecting it's like all of the
cords that were plugged in charging all
of the different aspects of your
personality and functionality got ripped
out of the wall during chemo and now I'm
just slowly figuring out how to plug
them back in some of them don't fit the
plugs that they had before so we got to
figure that out now I'm in the process
of getting back in touch with my
sexuality with my femininity with my
sense of self that's part of it man
there's so many things that are part of
this I did it I talked about the one
that makes my shoulders stand up to my
ears now we can talk about the other
ones emotional sensitivity this was
unexpected but not entirely surprising
obviously the worse you feel the less
you want to watch programs about people
feeling bad or doing bad hurting in any
way physically or emotionally I could
not watch programs that were sad
depressing violent at all had Whispers
of tragedy bodies being mutilated or
hurt anything that was kind of gross I
ended up leaning hard into reality
television which obviously has its cons
as there's a lot of screaming and
fighting going on but for some reason to
me there's just like an inherent
campiness in it that made it kind of
easy for me to watch and also tune out
it's kind of good soft focus programming
I started watching The Love is one
documentary that cult doc doumentary but
I haven't been able to finish the last
episode because just the way her body is
getting bad I just it it's a no for me
dog I'm curious I want to see how the
story ends but I just couldn't
physically watch her body go through
that see I'm fine there was a heightened
sensitivity to emotional programming
anything sad was really sad here's some
other physical side effects chemo brain
or fog brain you are told you will
experience slowdown of the brain
function some foggy cloudy behavior
cognitively
and clearly I'm still recovering from it
sentences don't come out as silky smooth
as they used to did they ever I know
that my Cadence
is like that sometimes but man there
really became some gaps and some pauses
the way I talk talked was like a London
Underground mind the gap I'm pretty
forgetful and Spacey on a normal basis
but there was a whole lot more of
walking into rooms and not remembering
what I was there for not remembering
what the end of my sentence was and or
remembering things that I needed to do
in general so there was a lot of note
taking notebooks everywhere writing in
my notes app my brain turned just into
like a colander everything just fell
through that's not a colander my brain
turned into a hole things kind of went
in there and then they got lost in there
someday they'll shoot back out maybe
we'll see I know people have also
recommended um there's apps for like
brain cognition that I know people that
have gone through cancer treatment have
used just to try and keep their brains
sharp so that's something to look into
if you're interested um I didn't
especially because one of the other side
effects is my vision got really
sensitive to screens which became such a
fight because all I wanted to do on the
days I felt like was numb out and
watch something on my phone my computer
or my TV but my eyes didn't really enjoy
it blue blockers came in really handy I
thought perhaps I was having some sort
of stroke but no again just getting
through cancer treatment and the other
crazy thing too is that my brain would
sometimes forget that I was currently
feeling like because of breast
cancer treatment so when a side effect
would come up I'd be like oh I must have
the flu what
with all of that I was also extremely
clumsy captain in butter fingers almost
every single day things were dropped
corners of the house were hit with all
of the appendages every pointy part of
my body I think got bruised at some
point hitting a countertop hitting a
corner tripping over a rug dropping a
mug lots of Three Stooges Behavior but
not as Charming oh I hardly sweat at all
hardly any sweating the only times that
I would really feel any sort of
potential sweat was the hot flashes got
a lot of hot flashes from you know the
menopausal State my body was forced into
cooling sheets big win then there's also
the hyper fixations as you saw I got
hyper fixated on Banana Pancakes but
then I would get really I would just
binge full seasons of reality
programming I would just wake up feeling
like today I'm going to become the
couch and I'm going to put on a program
and I'm going to watch about 12 episodes
of it until I knock myself out with
sleeping medication you do what you do
to get through that could be a saying
I've talked about this before I grew a
huge sensitivity to dirt gme mustiness
muskiness more than I've ever had before
so I developed a system the day before
the day after my chemo infusions when
I'm full of the steroid that they put
you on the steroid makes you up an atom
and one of the side effects is insomnia
you can use that to your advantage
before the onslaught of the side effects
I would get into a system of washing my
bed sheet vacuuming the flooring the
dishing the dog a bath and cleaning the
bathroom so that when I was in that sad
sloth state things at least were as
clean as they could be a lot of people
had suggested for nausea to buy alcohol
wipes and I did and I never really used
them for nausea probably because I
forgot however cleaning the bathrooms
and leaving that lingering smell of a
Clorox wipe really kind of helped me out
the same way I imagine sniffing an
alcohol wipe helps with nausea because
as we all know the majority of my time
in recovery if not in bed I was lording
over my bathroom tiles high at top my
porcelain Throne I was in the bathroom a
lot stuff was coming out all the time
having recently cleaned the bathroom
with the smell of the Clorox wipe in
there truly did help me feel less
nauseous also just my nightstands wiping
those down with a Clorox wipe before my
week of recovery help Elliot God bless
him would wash dishes every single night
and that was so so helpful just seeing
dirty dishes in the sink gave me the ick
deep into the darkest corners of my body
the house didn't have to be Immaculate
but there were certain things like clean
sheets God having clean sheets so
important let's see what else is on my
list hot flashes yes not a day goes by
that I don't get hives just out of
General excitement over the most minor
thing my body is sensitive and react but
I'd never experienced a hot flash before
that came on from no emotional stimulus
that was really fun chemo rash a pretty
common side effect I found out after
looking it up from getting chemo rash
after my first round of chemo It
generally shows up along your chest neck
face shoulders sometimes as just little
pimples or blistery looking things I got
it kind of on my neck and then it kind
of went into my face my first round my
doctor gave me an antibiotic to take it
kind of went away shortly after but then
the rest of my treatment it kind of
became a less intense but expected thing
my second week of recovery generally
after all of the worst physical symptoms
the rash would show up didn't itch or
bother me it just looked like I had a
breakout and eventually it would go away
also I joined a Facebook group right
away that was recommended to me for
triple positive breast cancer
specifically they're just an amazing
resource there's so many people with so
much information and so much experience
trying to help that's how I found out
what the chemo rash was if anything it
gave me a peace of mind immediately to
realize it was normal and easily
treatable what else Banana Pancakes yes
I talked about those okay all right that
I think for now from what I can remember
and was able to list are all of the
unexpected and slightly surprising side
effects that I experien during my breast
cancer treatment curious what side
effects you might have had that were
unexpected for you leave comments down
below it is one of the wildest Things is
that everyone has different experience
on the same drugs maybe that's just part
for the course of drugs
but we are getting all of these things
back our body is course correcting and
finding new ways uh to be a body how
exciting and one last reminder Link in
the description for the Bessa giveaway
again everyone that signs up is getting
a free vibrator or a gift card for a
vibrator so what do you got to lose your
free time cuz you'll have something to
do thank you guys for watching this
video I hope maybe this helps in some
way again I'll be making a these are the
products that worked for me uh during
treatment soon so look forward to that
wow quite a ride a lot of stuff in this
video
and well damn that camera battery just
died so looks like it's time to wrap up
this video thank you so much for
watching I'll see you next time I make a
video other than that I don't know